this video I'm going to talk about the
regulation of GPCR mediated signaling as
we have seen earlier that GPCR mediated
signaling is pretty important for
chemical receptor signaling and also in
a clinical point of view so the
initiation of the signaling is important
as well as the termination of the signal
is also important the whole mechanism
works like a circuit so it have to be
switched on it has to be switched off
switching one on mechanism is pretty
important so switching off mechanism is
also very important if this circuit is
not switched off it will go for in
finite time and that won't help that
actually be harmful for the cell so
however there are three mechanisms for
switching off this total signaling
cascade one mechanism is there are
certain kinase is that phosphorylate
these membrane associated g-protein this
G protein-coupled receptor get get
phosphorylated by a specific kindnesses
as you can see and this phosphorylated
GPCR is actually docking site for
arresting as the name suggests they
actually arrest this gpcr and this GPCR
in arresting bound form cannot bind to
this trimeric g and this trimeric
g-protein as this gpcr cannot bind to
the trimeric g-protein the further
downstream signaling pathway cannot take
place and the second mechanism is by our
GS or regulator of g protein so
regulator of g protein what it does it
actually hydrolysis the gtp into gtp so
actually it increases the gtp as
activity so in this second strategy then
upon leakin winding the alpha subunit
gets activated but further its activity
is reduced by this RGS so in the third
mechanism what happens the receptor gets
internalized
and the internalized receptor forms
indosoul and this n dissolve infused to
lysosome and get degraded or this
receptor can be recycled back by our
search mechanism so these are the three
basic mechanism by which the GPC are
signaling cascade could be regulated
hope you liked this video please
subscribe and comment